you've covered the cowboys for a long
time
i assume you were watching it as it
happened
walk us through
what your emotions were what your
reaction was at the time that
uh dak prescott went down
yeah i've covered so many of these and
and i did participate on the
conference calls with mike mccarthy and
andy dalton uh after the cowboys victory
that felt like a loss and that's exactly
what it felt like but you just remember
all of these that tony romo
took and and went out of the game but
this was just chilling i mean i still
have chills now it was just horrifying
and i don't want to see the video of
that again it was just gruesome a
gruesome injury is probably the best
way to put it and you just feel so bad
for dak i mean he's one of the good guys
in this league and if you ever get to
meet him to get to know him he he really
truly truly you will root for him
because
he does this league very good and you
hate to see good players go out we want
to see the best quarterbacks we want to
see the best players we want to see the
best guys in this game and so the
cowboys won't have him the rest of the
season and his future now i think is
very much in doubt about what happens
after this year contract wise
yeah and the future is also in doubt
short term from a health standpoint we
always hear when nfl players have any
type of surgery first the surgery was a
success and then before too long after
that the player's actually ahead of
schedule in his recovery and in many
cases that's true because professional
athletes
tend to heal differently tend to rebound
better
to physical adversity than the rest of
us but we still need to pay attention to
what happens with dak prescott because
there are risks to the extent that the
bone did pierce through the skin that
introduces a much higher risk of
infection that's what happened to alex
smith there's all sorts of bacteria and
other stuff on your skin that gets into
your body that way and it shouldn't be
in there and if they're not careful and
one of the things they did last night in
fixing the ankle was to wash the wound
thoroughly those are all things we need
to be concerned about as the days and
weeks go by the healing of the bone was
there other ligament damage these are
things that they're not going to
advertise right out of the gates these
are things that they're going to be very
circumspect about but shireen we've got
months before the next wave of decisions
need to be made but those months are
going to go by quickly
and running parallel to the passage of
time
the recovery or lack thereof from dak
prescott which is really going to shape
the decisions that eventually are made
yeah no question and mike this is a guy
that was still on track despite passing
for less than 200 yards before he went
out yesterday he was on track to break
the nfl record to pass for almost 6 000
yards
he was passing for almost 400 yards a
game and and just looked outstanding uh
week in and week out and yes he had a
few turnovers here and there but you
know he was really playing at a high
level and i think if the cowboys could
have turned it around and played better
on defense this is a guy you might have
been talking about alongside with josh
allen and russell wilson for for mvp
candidates and we obviously weren't
because of the cowboys record but he had
just put up some huge yards and and was
earning every bit of that huge contract
that he was going to get after the
season of course playing this year
under the franchise tag at 31.4 million
so
the future yes very much in doubt the
cowboys obviously want him on their team
steven jones reiterated that today he is
our future and and the cowboys still
believe in him but there are going to be
questions i mean there how can you not
have questions
considering the injury that he just had
yeah and uh
he would have been the offensive player
of the year if he stayed on pace as of
last week we were talking about 25 of
the season done he was on pace for six
seven six zero it it was one of those
things where i had to do the math three
times before my brain would process the
extent to which he was on pace to
shatter the single season passing
yardage record of 54.77 so or 57-44 i
get those two mixed up for some reason
regardless he was on pace to do
something that had never been done
before and that that's and that's the
first time i've even thought of it in
the 24 hours since it happened because
it's such a tragic turn of events it
really
forces you to reconsider everything you
think about the nfl and it's amazing
that injuries like this don't happen
more often but when they do they are
devastating stephen jones the cowboys
ceo among other titles discussed earlier
today
the impact of the injury and what it
means for dak's future with the dallas
cowboys
that conversation with him what was that
conversation like you know how much uh
our prayers are with him
how much we believe in him how much
we're going to miss but at the same time
knows if he's going to come back better
stronger
better than ever with our face of our
franchise
that happened and know that you'll
overcome nothing you'll overcome this
driven special name
face of the franchise shireen here's how
he stays the face of the franchise and
it's very
simple to identify the options it's not
going to be nearly as simple to pick one
but it's simple to identify them after
the regular season ends the window
reopens on the cowboys signing dac to a
multi-year deal now nothing stops them
from negotiating a long-term deal right
now you just can't sign it until the
regular season ends from then
until the deadline for application of
the franchise tag typically late
february sometimes early march the
cowboys have the exclusive right to talk
to dak with that hammer if they choose
to use it up the franchise tag a second
time so option one
sign to a long-term deal before the
window closes on using the franchise tag
option two
use the franchise tag and i'll include
the transition tag here as well because
it costs the same 20 raise over what he
made in 2020 regardless what the salary
cap does salary cap goes down to 175
doesn't matter the 20 raise still
applies under the cba that's
37.68 million dollars or 21.5
of
the potential salary cap for next year
due to pandemic if it does drop to 175
million that's option two option three
you don't get a deal done
you don't apply the franchise tag he
becomes a free agent and maybe that's
ultimately what happens maybe he hits
the open market and other teams don't
pursue him with that kind of money that
we typically see free agents and it's
really great free agents that get to the
open market it's usually mid-level guys
but they get paid a lot of money because
they're the ones available but maybe he
goes to the open market the cowboys see
what other teams may pay and then the
cowboys finally give him what he wants
but in the background of all of this is
his health
so again the options are simple
but the final selection is going to be
greatly complicated by how healthy he is
or isn't when that franchise tag
deadline rolls around next year
and no question they want to sign him to
a long-term deal they've been wanting to
do that for the past two years and they
never could settle on the years you know
cowboys wanted five years dak won in
four years he is bad on himself and he's
gonna end up getting his money the
question is how much do the cowboys end
up giving him and do they give in and
just go the four-year route but they've
to in my opinion they've got to sign him
to a long-term deal just for cap
implications because they can do so many
more things and manipulate the cap he
just can't be that big of a percentage
of the cap on the franchise tag so
they've got to do something else and at
this point i think they've got to get
him signed to a long-term deal they've
got to roll the dice that he's going to
come back and be the same guy that they
saw this season that they saw the season
before in the season before that
that he can return to to help and you do
wonder a little bit mike about his
uh running ability uh with this injury
because that was one of his strengths
was his ability to get outside the
pocket is he going to be the same guy
running the football and getting outside
the pocket that he was before this
injury
yeah and you know that whole four years
versus five years maybe this time around
dak prescott more amenable to five years
because he understands that the cowboys
assuming the risk that maybe in 2021
they're going to be paying a lot of
money to a guy who isn't ready to go
week one and maybe dak prescott just
chooses to wait it can become like a cam
newton type of a situation very quickly
if they can't work out a deal he becomes
a free agent other teams are reluctant
the cowboys are reluctant and dak just
decides you know what i'll just wait to
sign until i'm healthy and he may have
to take what he can get to prove he's
healthy with the cowboys or someone else
before
he
cashes in with the contract that he has
long deserved so look
the bottom line is
the healing of the ankle the recovery
from the injury is going to drive this
discussion the problem is there are
deadlines that are going to emerge
before potentially we know how healthy
he is or isn't and what track he's on
and that's going to potentially
change everything whether it's the
cowboys or someone else but there are
other teams out there and i tried to
list them earlier today at pft every
year there are teams looking for
starting quarterbacks and you know what
for some of these teams they've been so
desperate for so long to find somebody
who can come in and play at a high level
maybe you just roll the dice maybe you
pay the money you bite the bullet and
you deal with the possibility he may not
be ready right away especially if let's
say you're washington and you'd love
nothing more than to grab
the franchise quarterback that your
division rival thought they were going
to have for the next 15 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports